after a series of teases Rockstar Games  has officially announced Red Dead  Redemption - I'm Tony and yes this game  spot news update is really happening  Rockstar released official artwork  featuring seven characters on a red  background and they just might be the  game's ensemble cast the developer also  stated that the game quote is an epic  tale of life in America's unforgiving  Heartland  as for gameplay Rockstar has offered no  details although a web domain for Red  Dead online was recently discovered  additionally a trailer will be released  this Thursday October 20th Red Dead  Redemption 2 is coming to Xbox one and  ps4 in fall 2017 rockstar made no  mention of a PC version and considering  the original hasn't even come to PC it's  probably best not to get your hopes up  but keep an eye on GameSpot for tons of  new information when the trailer drops  and for all the biggest rock star news  you're already in the right place